GREG GUTFELD.
5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY, THIS IS
"THE FIVE"."
A LOT OF BIG 2020 NEWS TO TELL
YOU ABOUT INCLUDING
BERNIE SANDERS REFUSING TO BACK
AWAY FROM HIS LOVE AFFAIR WITH
COMMUNIST CUBA AND WILL MANY
MICHAEL BLOOMBERG TAKE ANOTHER
DEEP STOMACH BEATING ON THE
DEBATE STATION I?
FIRST, PRESIDENT TRUMP MIXING UP
WITH THE LIBERAL MEDIA BEFORE
LEAVING FOR INDIA, HITTING BACK
AGAINST THE FAILING NARRATIVE
THAT RUSSIA IS TRYING TO HELP
HIM GET REELECTED.
>> THEY NEVER TOLD ME ANYTHING
ABOUT THAT AND IT WAS A STRANGE
THING, IT WAS HIGHLY EXAGGERATED
AND FRANKLY, I THINK IT IS
DISGRACEFUL AND I THINK IT WAS
WEEKS FROM THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE.
I THINK PROBABLY ADAM SCHIFF
WEEK DID IN MY OPINION AND HE
SHOULDN’T BE LEAKING THINGS LIKE
THAT, THAT’S A TERRIBLE THING TO
DO.
>> Jesse: PRESIDENT TRUMP
SAVING HIS BEST JOBS FOR CNN’S
JIM ACOSTA.
>> I WANT TO KNOW HOW FROM ANY
COUNTRY AND IF YOU SEE WHAT CNN,
YOUR WONDERFUL NETWORK SAID, I
GUESS THEY APOLOGIZED IN A
WAY -- DIDN’T THEY APOLOGIZED
FOR THE FACT THAT THEY SAID
CERTAIN THINGS THAT WEREN’T
TRUE?
WHAT WAS THEIR APOLOGY
YESTERDAY?
WHAT DID THEY SAY?
>> I THINK OUR RECORD ON
DELIVERING THE TRUTH IS A LOT
BETTER THAN YOURS.
>> LET ME TELL YOU ABOUT YOUR
RECORD, YOU’VE GOT TO BE ASHAMED
OF YOURSELF.
>> I’M NOT ASHAMED OF ANYTHING.
>> THE WORST RECORD IN THE
HISTORY OF BROADCASTING.
>> Jesse: SORE LOSER
HILLARY CLINTON HAD GOT OVER
2016, SHE IS BACK ABOUT RUSSIA.
>> WE KNOW THE RUSSIANS ARE
CONTINUING TO TRY TO CHOOSE OUR
NEXT PRESIDENT LIKE THEY CHOSE
OUR LAST PRESIDENT AND WE JUST
HAVE TO BE MORE VIGILANT AND
PEOPLE HAVE TO PAY ATTENTION TO
TRYING TO GET THE BEST POSSIBLE
INFORMATION AND DON’T BELIEVE
EVERYTHING YOU SEE ON THE
INTERNET.
THAT IS ONE OF THE GREATEST
CHALLENGES FACING DEMOCRACY
RIGHT NOW.
>> Jesse: SHE USED TO SAY THIS
WAS MY EXCUSE AND THIS WAS MY
EXCUSE BUT I’VE LOST IT I TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY.
THAT IS OUT THE WINDOW NOW, NOW
SHE IS SAYING RUSSIA CHOSE DRUM.
>> Dana: YOU CAN NEVER
ACTUALLY HEAL FROM AN ELECTION
IF YOU ARE NOT HONEST.
SHE TRULY SEEMS TO BELIEVE THAT
RUSSIA GAVE PRESIDENT TRUMP THE
ELECTION.
THERE HAVE BEEN SEVERAL
INVESTIGATIONS OF THE HIGHEST
LEVELS OF THE GOVERNMENT NOT
HAVE NOT PROVEN THAT TO BE SO
AND YES, DOES RUSSIA WANT TO PUT
SOME ADS OUT THERE CAME AFTER
THEY LIKE TO METAL?
PROBABLY, BUT I THINK FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP ONE OF THE WAYS
TO ANSWER THOSE QUESTIONS AS TO
SAY I DON’T NEED THEIR HELP.
I HAVE A RECORD, I RAN ON THIS
RECORD, I DON’T NEED YOUR HELP
AND IF YOU ARE TRYING TO HELP
ME, I DON’T NEED YOUR HELP,
SOMETHING LIKE THAT THAT WOULD
BE MORE DERISIVE OF RUSSIA
RATHER THAN BUILDING THEM UP TO
BE SOMETHING THAT THEY ARE NOT.
>> Jesse: JIM ACOSTA, THE
NERVE TO SAY THAT CNN HAS A
GREAT TRACK RECORD ON TELLING
THE TRUTH.
I DON’T KNOW.
>> Greg: CNN’S RATINGS ARE IN
STEEP DECLINE AND WE SEE THAT
BECAUSE WE SEE THE RATINGS EVERY
DAY AND IT IS BECAUSE I BELIEVE
THEY’VE LOST THE TRUST OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE BY BECOMING THE
WEEKLY WORLD NEWS FOR TRUMPED
ARRANGEMENT.
THEY CAN LINK THE BATBOY TO
TRUMP, THEY ARE GOING TO PUT IT
ON THE COVER, SO I’M GOING TO GO
ON A BIT OF A RANT AGAINST THE
MEDIA, GOING TO TRY SOMETHING
NEW IF YOU DON’T MIND.
>> Juan: WHY TRY ANYTHING NEW?
>> Greg: THIS IS AN EPIPHANY.
SO WE HAVE WATCHED THAT
SHATTERED, EMBARRASSMENT AFTER
EMBARRASSMENT.
WE HAVE BEEN LIVING DECADES KIND
OF IN THIS SEAL NARRATIVE OF
CULTIVATED STORIES THAT HELP
MAKE MONEY FOR THESE CORPORATIST
COMPANIES, OUR THINKING IS NOT
ABOUT THE EVENTS WHICH ARE
RUSSIA, COVINGTON, KAVANAUGH, IS
THE FACT IT ALL HAPPENED IN A
CONCENTRATED TIME ALL IN
SUCCESSION.
IT USED TO BE ISOLATED, THINGS
LIKE RICHARD JEWELL BUT IN THE
LAST FOUR YEARS, WE HAVE SEEN SO
MANY OF THEM AND I’M BEGINNING
TO WONDER IF IT’S BECAUSE THEY
WERE MORE OF THEM OR BECAUSE WE
HAVE BECOME SO RED FILLED THAT
NOW WE FINALLY SEE THEM FOR WHAT
THEY ARE AND NOW WE QUESTION
ANYTHING THAT WE DIDN’T QUESTION
BEFORE LIKE WE QUESTION ARE WE
GETTING THE RIGHT STUFF ABOUT
CORONAVIRUS?
ARE WE GETTING THE REAL STORY
AND I THINK THAT IS SUPER
HEALTHY THAT NOW WE DO NOT TRUST
THIS AND ONE OF TRUMPS BIG
ACHIEVEMENTS IS THAT HE PUT A
SCAR ACROSS THE FACE OF MEDIA
THAT WILL NEVER GO AWAY AND
EVERYBODY CAN SEE THAT SCAR FOR
THE REST OF THEIR LIVES AND I
THINK IT’S SUPER IMPORTANT.
>> Dana: THERE IS SOME
EVIDENCE THAT RUSSIA HAS BEEN
SPREADING MISINFORMATION ABOUT
THE CORONAVIRUS ONLINE TO
BECAUSE PEOPLE FEAR AND CHAOS
AND THAT IS SOMEPLACE WHERE
PRESIDENT TRUMP COULD TURN
AROUND AND SAY KNOCK IT OFF.
ENOUGH OF THAT AND I THINK HE’S
IN A POSITION WHERE HE CAN DO
THAT.
>> Jesse: BABY YOU’RE SEEING
ALL OF THESE KIND OF FAKE NEW
SCANDALS AS GREG MENTIONED
HAPPENING IN A CONDENSED PERIOD
OF TIME BECAUSE THE MEDIA IS SO
DESPERATE, THEY HAVE TO
MANUFACTURE THIS TO GET TRUMP
OUT OF OFFICE AS FAST AS
POSSIBLE AND BECAUSE IT’S A
24-HOUR NEWS CYCLE NOW, THEY
HAVE TO KEEP GENERATING RATING
AFTER RATING.
I SAW CNN DO A THING YESTERDAY
THAT TRUMP WAS GOING TO FREAK
OUT BECAUSE THERE IS NO BEEF AND
THEY HAD THREE REPORTERS
ASSIGNED TO THE BYLINE.
>> Greg: IS THE PRESIDENT
GOING TO BE ABLE TO SURVIVE
INDIA ON VEGETARIAN MEALS.
I THINK THEY WERE BIGGER ISSUES
TO TALK ABOUT.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT RUSSIA LOVES?
RUSSIA LOVES THAT AMERICANS ARE
GETTING PITTED AGAINST EACH
OTHER WHICH IS WHAT THEY ARE
TRYING TO DO AND THAT THEY ARE
TALKING ABOUT RUSSIA.
THEY ARE NOT INTERESTED IN A
CERTAIN CANDIDATE WHETHER IT’S
BERNIE SANDERS OR DONALD TRUMP
OR HILLARY CLINTON.
THEY JUST WANT US FIGHTING WITH
EACH OTHER WHEN PEOPLE LIKE
ADAM SCHIFF GO AN ENTIRE
IMPEACHMENT PROCESS AND HOURS ON
THE FLOOR TALKING ABOUT RUSSIA
WHETHER IT’S THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION DRAGGING OUT,
PEOPLE ON TELEVISION MAKING THIS
CLAIM AND THE LATEST CLAIM THEY
HAD TO WALK BACK SAYING THEY ARE
HELPING BERNIE SANDERS WHEN THE
PRIMARY NOW, RUSSIA DOESN’T
CARE, THEY ONLY CARE THAT WE ARE
FIGHTING WITH EACH OTHER AND
AMERICANS ARE AT EACH OTHER’S
THROATS AND THAT’S EXACTLY WHAT
THEY’VE BEEN SUCCESSFUL AT DOING
FOR THE PAST THREE YEARS OF THE
QUESTION IS ARE PEOPLE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO ALLOW THEM TO DO
THAT?
WE ARE SO CONCERNED ABOUT
RUSSIAN MEDDLING, WHY DO WE STOP
GETTING THEM SO MUCH CREDIT FOR
SOMETHING THEY’RE NOT IN CONTROL
OF.
>> Jesse: IF YOU USE COMMON
SENSE, WOULDN’T YOU THINK THAT
HE WOULD WANT BERNIE SINCE
BERNIE WANTS TO SLASH DEFENSE
SPENDING?
HE WANTS TO GET RID OF SPACE FOR
US.
>> Juan: THIS HAS BEEN SO
TWISTED HERE AT THIS TABLE I
DON’T EVEN KNOW WHERE TO START.
HILLARY CLINTON DID NOT GO OFF
ABOUT THE RUSSIANS HELPING
DONALD TRUMP, WHICH HE SAID WAS
THE RUSSIANS CONTINUE TO
INTERFERE, CONTINUE TO SPREAD
MISINFORMATION.
AND LET ME JUST SAY, THEY NOT
ONLY HAVE TO CLEAR WOW
HILLARY CLINTON IF YOU WILL
RECALL, BUT THEY USED IT AGAINST
HER CAMPAIGN WEAPONIZE THE
INFORMATION IN SUCH A WAY THAT
DROVE MAINSTREAM MEDIA TO COVER
IT AS IF IT WAS NEWS.
AND THEY WERE PLAYED ALONG LIKE
A BUNCH OF FOOLS AND THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND THEN YOU SAY
SAY.
THEY CERTAINLY DID NOT AND NOT
ONLY DID THEY DO THAT, THEY WENT
AFTER SO MANY OTHER THINGS
INCLUDING MY PHONE NUMBER.
SO I WANT TO TELL YOU SOMETHING
THAT’S VERY REAL.
BEFORE YOU DISTORT IT,
HILLARY CLINTON SAYS YOU HAVE TO
BE CAREFUL ABOUT WHAT YOU READ
ON THE INTERNET AND
MISINFORMATION.
THAT IS THE TRUTH.
>> Jesse: RUSSIA, IF YOU’RE
LISTENING.
>> Juan: LET ME ADD SOMETHING
HERE.
YOU’VE GOT TO UNDERSTAND THAT I
WILL TAKE TRUMP AT HIS WORD THAT
HE WASN’T TOLD ABOUT RUSSIA
INTERFERING TO HELP HIM BECAUSE
REMEMBER, I THINK IT WAS ONE OF
HIS CHIEF OF STAFF THAT TOLD
CHRISTIAN NEARKIRSTJEN NIELSEN T
MENTION ANYTHING ABOUT RUSSIA
AND TRUMP SO MAYBE PEOPLE DON’T
WANT TO TELL HIM BUT LET’S ALSO
TAKE IT AT FACE BECAUSE IT IS
ALSO TRUE THAT RUSSIA INTERFERED
IN 2016 AND EVERYBODY WHO HAS
INVESTIGATED FROM THE TOP LEVELS
OF GOVERNMENT TO PEOPLE WHO ARE
ONLINE SAYING THE BOTS AND THE
RUSSIANS CONTINUE TO INTERFERE.
>> Jesse: IN ORDER TO PUSH THE
STORY FOR FOUR YEARS, YOU HAVE
TO IGNORE THE BIGGEST FOREIGN
INTERFERENCE STORY AT ALL WHICH
IS THIS DOSSIER.
YOU GUYS SIT AND TALK ABOUT BOTS
BOTS.
YOU COULD NOT BE TAKEN
SERIOUSLY.
>> Juan: EVERY NIGHT, IT’S THE
MEDIA.
TRUMP USES THE INTERNET JUST
LIKE THE RUSSIANS.
>> Jesse: WANT, STOP TALKING.
YOU ARE KILLING YOURSELF, JUAN.
A >> Juan: DONALD TRUMP IS
KILLING AMERICA.
>> Jesse: YOU JUST GOT BACK
FROM DISNEY WORLD.